Bailey: Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm John Bailey from the
University of Alaska, Fairbanks.
And I'm in San Francisco
this week to help run
a special session
on the use of virtual globes
at the fall meeting of
the American Geophysical Union.
We're running a session this
year in conjunction with Google,
so as sort of part
of the week's events
we've invited along
a few of the scientists
that are using Google Earth
and KML for display purposes
of their data to come down
to the downtown Google offices
and talk about their work.
And to start things off,
our first presenter
is Lisa Ballagh,
who works at the snow and ice--
National Snow and Ice Data
Center in Boulder, Colorado.
And she's gonna be talking
about how they visualize
data from glaciers
in Google Earth.
Ballagh: Thank you, John.
As John mentioned,
I'm gonna be talking today
about two glacier data sets
in particular,
and how we can view them
in Google Earth.
And then I'm also gonna
be talking about GeoServer
and the role that GeoServer
plays in this project.
I'd like to acknowledge
my co-authors
Ethan Wang and Elena Wallace.
They have contributed
tremendously to this work
and I'd really like
to acknowledge their support.
Before I get into the talk,
I'd like to give you
a little bit of background first
on the National Snow and Ice
Data Center.
As John mentioned, we're located
in Boulder, Colorado.
And we're a big data archive,
so we have tons and tons
of satellite imagery,
we have imagery from submarines.
Or data, I should say,
from submarines.
And we also have
photo collections.
We manage and disseminate
different snow and ice
data center,
and we're funded primarily
by NASA, NOAA, and the NSF.
The work that I'm gonna
be talking today--
about today is funded by NOAA's
National Geophysical
Data Center.
I should say that
at the National Snow
and Ice Data Center,
most people come
to our website looking for data.
However, if they're
not looking for data,
the most--the second-most
popular search term
that they're looking for
is information on glaciers.
So I'm gonna be talking today
about two different
glacier data sets.
The Glacier
Photograph Collection
and the World Glacier Inventory.
I'm gonna be showing how you can
visualize them in Google Earth,
and I'm gonna use GeoServer
to do this,
and then at the very end
I'm gonna be talking
about our NSIDC
Virtual Globe site.
We have a glacier
photograph collection
where we have glaciers
that extend back to the 1880s.
And then we have
information up to 2005.
This is a really neat collection
because it was donated to NSIDC
in the, um--by William Field
back in the 1970s.
And coverage primarily includes
Alaskan and Greenland glaver--
glaciers, although we do
have limited coverage
in other areas such as Canada,
Europe, New Zealand, and Peru.
This data set
is actually really important.
It's one of our
most popular data sets at NSIDC.
We have--it's doubled
in size this year,
since January of 2008.
And with many contributions
by the USGS
Ice and Climate Project,
with many contributions
from Austin Post.
We now have over 10,000
glacier photographs online.
And this is a whole
project with accessibility,
because when we received
this huge collection
from William Field a while ago.
He gave us tons and tons
of glacier photographs,
but we had
the photographic prints.
In order to actually
view this information
you had to go
to Boulder, Colorado,
and you had to go
into our analog archives room,
and you could flip through
all the various
different photographs.
Which is great, however,
thanks to NOAA's Climate
Database Modernization Program,
we have digitized
a lot of these photographs,
and now they're
available online.
We do have
several, um, thousand glaciers
that are not--er, prints that
are not available online yet,
but we are working with NOAA's
CDMP program to get this funded
and made available online.
This just gives you
an example of Arapaho Glacier
in 1912, 1966, and in 2004.
and you can kind of see
how the glaciers have--
how this particular glacier
has retreated over time.
A subset of our collection
is a set of repeat photographs,
where a photographer
will go to an exact location
and specifically try and repeat
a photograph from the past.
So, for example, this is
Holgate Glacier in Alaska,
taken in July of 1909,
and then taken again by
Bruce Molnia in August of 2004.
And what's really neat about
this is that you can
visually see some
of the retreat that's happened
with various glaciers over time,
and this is really what
the public are interested in.
Everyone is coming to our site
looking for glaciers,
and so we have
these photos now online,
and we've also created
several different KML files
so that you can
zoom into Google Earth,
you can go to Alaska, look
at the different placemarks.
You click on a placemark
and it pops up information
in Google Earth.
What's also important
about the Google Earth work
that we've done
is that we have information--
we have our metadata
associated with these
glacier photographs.
So you don't just have glacier
photographs without any context.
We have information
about each specific glacier
photograph in our collection,
and this is really the most
important part, I think,
because you can view the photos,
which are obviously
very interesting,
but without the metadata
you don't really know
what you're looking at,
and it's not very useful.
I just talked about the glacier
photograph collection,
but the second data set
I'm gonna talk about
is our world glacier
inventory data set.
So while the glacier photos
are actually photographs,
this is more raw data
and statistics about glaciers.
This collection
has over 100,000 glaciers,
and it's a snapshot in time.
So we have information
such as latitude and longitude
of the glacier,
the total area,
the mean depth, and so on.
Our objective--our objective
was to make this information
accessible through Google Earth.
Now, with the glacier
photograph collection,
we have static KML files,
and when the glacier photograph
collection is updated,
we have to update our KML files
to make sure
that they are in sync.
With the World Glacier
Inventory it's--
it was just
too large to do this.
We have over 100,000 records.
If we created a KML file,
it would be thousands
and thousands of pages long,
and it would probably crash
if you tried to open it
in Google Earth.
So we had to come up
with some kind of solution,
and we wanted it to be
a dynamic solution
because every time we update
the World Glacier Inventory
we don't want to actually go in
and manually update
the KML file.
We want this
to be done automatically.
So our solution was
to use GeoServer for this,
which will dynamically request
area-specific information.
So to get our World Glacier
Inventory from the--
from our one database into KML,
we're using GeoServer.
If you're not familiar
with GeoServer,
here's a diagram
that kind of shows you
the different inputs
that you can use.
So we have inputs
for the World Glacier--
I'm using the World Glacier
Inventory for this,
and then you can have
different output options.
And what's nice about GeoServer
is that it automatically creates
these output options for you.
We're using Postgres,
um, as our input,
so we've loaded all of our
World Glacier Inventory data
into this database,
and then we're connecting it
to GeoServer,
and then GeoServer automatically
creates this KML output for us.
Here's a quick view
from Google Earth
of our World Glacier Inventory,
and I've kinda
zoomed in on Europe.
I've added a little placemark
here for the overview
to give you context
for what we're looking at.
And then we have
little red arrows,
and each red arrow represents
a glacier in our
World Glacier Inventory.
You can zoom in a little bit.
And zoom in a little bit more.
And you can click
on one of these icons
and it gives you
information about the data.
And this is pulled dynamically
from the database.
So the closer you zoom in,
it's recalculating,
"Oh, I'm only interested
in this particular region,
"I'm only gonna return
"these results to you
through GeoServer."
And I have formatted this
so that you can go back
to our documentation to get
information on the metadata.
All of the field names
I've included here
along with all of their values.
And, for example,
let's say you don't know
what one of the country
codes means.
You don't know what "CH" means.
You can click
on our documentation
and it has information on what
all the country codes mean,
and that helps you
better understand the data.
Michael Jones of Google
spoke last night
at the AGU conference
here in San Francisco,
and he was talking
about having scientists, uh,
communicate the results
and distribute their data,
and he mentioned that
a lot of scientists actually,
you know,
will distribute their data,
and they'll put it online,
but sometimes they don't
have any information--
they don't have
any column headers.
So you can look at the data,
but it's not gonna
make any sense to you
because you don't know
what the values mean,
you don't even know
what the headers are.
That's analogous to the output
you'll get using GeoServer
if you don't use KML templates
and styled layer descriptors.
So in this example here,
I have used a KML template
and a styled layer descriptor
because if I don't,
you're gonna get this long table
with records from the database
and it--it--it's not gonna
really make any sense to you.
For example, topographic scale
in the database
might have a field name
of "topo_scale"
and you might not know
what that means,
and it just gives you
this long output.
So I formatted it to make it
a little bit easier
to understand in Google Earth.
At the heart of this,
of course, is GeoServer.
And the key with GeoServer
is interoperability.
So you can take data
from various different sources,
you can integrate it
into GeoServer,
and then you can use this
through several different
web mapping locations.
It supports OGC standards,
and you can share and edit
geospatial data.
And what I like about GeoServer
is that it's GUI-driven.
You don't have to
be a programmer
in order to be able
to use GeoServer.
And once GeoServer
is up and running,
you can load
your data into GeoServer
and it automatically creates
the KML files for you.
And the GUI is very intuitive.
Another thing I should note
is that a lot of times
when you think
of open-source software,
you think, oh, well, it might
not be very well documented.
I must say
that I'm quite impressed
with the documentation
for GeoServer.
Several--
the open source community
has done a really good job
of putting information
together about GeoServer,
and whenever I have questions,
I resort back
to the documentation,
and I usually find the answers
that I'm looking for.
This is an example
of the GeoServer main page.
And from the main page I've
clicked on one of the layers.
This is the World Glacier
Inventory Layer.
And I'm clicking on "KML" here.
This--this page kind of lists
all the layers that you see,
along with all of the outputs.
You can also go in
and make configuration changes.
So you can go
to data and feature types.
And you can get
the World Glacier Inventory data
that you've just loaded.
And you can change the style.
Say, for example, you don't like
the red arrows that I have,
and you wanna have a little,
white snowflake instead.
You can create your own
styled layer descriptor,
and it's pretty easy.
You just, um, change
the style on this webpage,
hit "apply" and "save,"
and it's done for you.
So this is an outreach project
that we're working on,
and so we wanted
to take the data from GeoServer
and put it into Google Earth,
and we do this,
obviously, through KML.
And since this is auto-gen--
automatically generated,
it makes it really nice.
Um, as I mentioned,
the user output is not
very friendly at first,
but you can use templates
and styled layer descriptors
and make it much nicer.
Here's an example
styled layer descriptor.
This is just a little piece
of code that I took out of it.
But basically
I've highlighted that you can
put this "snowflake_thumb.gif"
file in here,
and it--and you have to
save this file in GeoServer,
but then everything
is snowflakes.
Every single glacier
will be a snowflake
instead of a red arrow
like I had it.
Here's an example KML template
that I've created.
This is just part of it,
but you can see, actually,
that part of the values in here,
for example,
"glacier_num.value,"
that's pulling information
dynamically from the database.
And as you can see, I'm pretty
much using HTML tags here.
So I don't have to know
how to program,
I don't have to know
how to create a KML file,
I just have to know
how to edit this template,
and all of the information
is available through
the GeoServer website.
Next, I'm gonna show you
our virtual globe site.
This is a site that we have
at the National Snow
and Ice Data Center.
And this has
all of our Google Earth files,
all in one place.
You can see
on the left-hand side
we have a little snapshot image
of the file,
and then we also
have the KML files
that you can download
along with the data source,
so that you can actually
go to the data source
and find out
more information about this.
I should note
that every file on this page
has been peer-reviewed.
We've set up
a peer review process
for all of our KML files.
Because our main goal
is we wanna create KML files,
but we don't wanna
make them unusable.
We wanna make KML files
that are of high quality.
And so at least
three people have viewed
every single file
that we've put on this website.
And our goal,
obviously, is for outreach
because we wanna make them
easier and more accessible
to a broader audience.
You can see the glaciers file
that I spoke about earlier.
That's right here.
You could download that.
And if you look through
this website, you will not find
the World Glacier Inventory file
that I spoke about earlier.
Why is this?
That's because it's on
our Google Earth
technical experiments page.
So we're really trying
to foster innovation at NSIDC,
and by doing this,
we wanna be able to have a way
to get files
out to the public
that have not been
peer reviewed,
but that are more innovative.
So if you look on this page,
the World Glacier Inventory file
that I was talking about
is here.
And this will go through
our peer review process,
it just has not yet.
But this lists various files
that we've been
experimenting with,
so if you're wondering
what we've been up to lately,
you can go to this site and
take a look at some of the files
that we have been working on.
This concludes my presentation.
As I mentioned,
this is an outreach initiative
to reach a broad audience.
We really wanna
get our data out there,
we want more people to use it,
and we wanna make it
as easy to use as possible.
A lot of people
like using Google Earth,
which is why
I've shown this, um, pre--
I've showed Google Earth
in this presentation,
but KML is an open standard,
so you can view KML
in other virtual globes,
such as
Microsoft's Virtual Earth.
GeoServer helps serve data
through Google Earth
and its open-source software,
which is why we have selected
Google--or, GeoServer.
And users can
view the glacier data sets
in a spatial environment.
Feel free to contact me
if you have any questions.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Are there any questions? Yes.
Man: It's not really a question,
per se.
It's an observation.
Ballagh: Okay.
Man: [indistinct]...
Ballagh: Great. Thank you.
I will just
repeat what he said.
Uh, he had more of a comment
rather than a question.
He's a teacher, and he uses--
he's used our sea ice images
in some of the classes
that he has taught,
and he's found them useful,
and he thanked us.
Yes.
Man: Does, uh, GeoServer support
export through [indistinct]?
Ballagh: That's a good question.
I don't know.
I should note, though,
that GeoServer does--
you can create--
you can add on to GeoServer,
so if it's not
available in GeoServer,
you can program it
and make it do that.
Okay. Thank you.
[applause]